Kym's rasuls on The Wall Street Journal
editorial board she's follows a subject
very closely and she joins us tonight so
Kim I hate to hit you with a story
that's just come out because now there
of us knows that much about it but I
just want your reaction since you cover
this we learned in the New York Times
piece 50 minutes ago that US Intel
agencies under the Trump administration
paid a hundred grand to get salacious
information and apparently false
information on Trump does that sound
kind of just like normal business as
usual to you no it does not because as
was just noted it's one thing to go out
and spend money potentially getting
information on a sworn enemy of the
United States it's another to go out and
spend a hundred thousand dollars trying
to get information on the
commander-in-chief yeah I mean infra and
presumably it's I mean according to The
Times piece it wasn't information that
suggested he was selling secrets to
anybody it was information of a sexual
nature that probably not even true but
like it's also irrelevant to American
security so let me ask you this
yeah do you find it striking that the
very people who a year ago said anyone
who claims Trump was spied on by the
Obama administration is a nutcase or
Alex Jones or whatever tinfoil hat type
those same people are now telling us
like yeah of course it's totally normal
for one administration to spy on a rival
presidential campaign like no big deal
this is the story of this entire
investigation Tucker think back first
we're told that the dossier was a
creation of a Republican funder turns
out it was the Clinton campaign in the
DNC then we're told that it couldn't
possibly have been used as part of a
FISA warrant turns out it was then we're
told it could have made up a big part of
it it turns out it was the main piece
now we're told well you know it doesn't
really matter because it wasn't really
spying on the Trump campaign it was
spying on a man who'd already left the
campaign only that's not true either it
turns out it was used to end up
following the conversations of Carter
Paige and whomever else he might have
been talking to Steve Bannon who's been
mentioned is potentially only one there
could be many other people that they
managed to capture because of this so
how could I mean it seems to me it's
critical in order to restore faith in
government that we know the details here
or else you know in the vacuum created
by ignorance
conspiracy theories gross like how do we
get to the bottom of what actually
happened well you know look for instance
at what happened when Senator Grassley
put out a less redacted version of his
referral letter of a criminal
investigation of Christopher Steele you
know we were told Oh none of that could
come out it would damage sources method
is highly classified you look at it and
you find out that the only thing that
was in fact redacted was information
that was highly scandalous and hurtful
to the FBI that undermined it and the
Justice Department so I my question is
why shouldn't we put out these FISA
applications let's put out all the
documents and see where the skeletons
are and yeah we can try to be careful of
sources and methods but this has now
become a farce of he-said she-said and
American public deserves to see it and
judge it with their own eyes yeah the
embarrassment of federal bureaucrats is
not justification for keeping something
secret that doesn't belong to them they
don't own these documents they belong to
us
so castle thanks for reminding us of all
that it was great thank you